Hello Everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to The Body.
Now, this game was made by the same developer of One Chance
and if you remember that game,
it was a flash game where you only had a single chance,
to save the entire world.
Admittedly, from your own mistake,
but if you wanna see that game you can check in the description below, but...
This one, I actually found, and uh, not a lot of people have played it,
And it seemed to be, from his description, another emotional game.
And, I wanted to give it a try, because when I opened it up,  it seemed very bizarre,
In that, it's presented in this real- woah
Oh no
My character was-
My character was just holding a body bag and it-
Oh no
Oh no x2
Oh no x3
Oh no x4
Oh no x5
Oh no x6
Why am I carrying a body?
Oh no x7
Well that took a turn real quick, it's amazing how something so s- spacebar to use?
Oh no, is that a shovel?
Oh, god
Okay
Let's leave that right there..
*mutters* Press spacebar to use
There we go, gotta be in the right spot for it
Hup, gotta keep diggin with the spacebar, gotta be good about it
Oh, hi.
Who the hell are you?
Ohhh no
Ohh no
Oh no
Aw, come on
Why you gotta make me do this, my character's still in black and white apparently
Oh no
Oh what happened
Do I wanna know what happened?
Hi?
Oh
Is the game waiting for me to do something because I don't think I wanna do it.
What's gonna happen when I press the spacebar?
What?
Oh!
Uh, Oh!
What??
Why did I kill that guy? (Girl)
I'm assuming that's what happened..
Oh, god
Oh, I can't even go that way
What the hell?
Oh my gawd
Ok?
Uh, I guess I'm running now? I suppose?
I don't even know how the police would've gotten here.
I mean, I don- Oh, my gawd
What?
Is this some sort of symbolism about me running away from the police?
And running away from my own crimes?
So who's that lady, and who's that guy
that just came- is this even real?
is the big question that I'm saying here.
and that's a cabin.
And I saw this as a painting
in the house I was just in.
If you look closely, this-
Whaarryookay?
Oh shit.
Wow.
That was a sudden, jarring change.
*softly* oh wow
that sent chills down my spine
Arrow keys to aim?
Oh no
What?
Oh my god
That's over so quickly!
I think he shot himself??
Hang on, I gotta go back and I gotta see if there's something else I coulda done there.
Oh, man
That like, I didn't even have a chance to realize what was happening.
like, I was trying to comprehend it while it was going under,
I don't know, lemme get back to that point again and then I can actually think rationally.
This must be,
this must be a bunch of bodies that I've buried over time
I-If I'm supposed to interpret this,
I would assume that this is all very symbolic, and this
is like,
an accelerated concept that we're supposed to understand -
this isn't taking place in immediate reality here.
This is like,
Oh man
Oh man, that transition right there, is jarring as hell.
So what happens if I...
go to the right
Oh man, that's so weird, like, it-
just the option
to shoot yourself, right then and there
and then there's no fanfare to it, it's just-
what did that mean?
what happened?
What did that mean?
What did THAT mean?
What are you doing?
You can't do this to me, what does it mean?
It's so obscure!
Aw, man!
Aw, is there something- I gotta find out if there's something else to it.
I gotta fin- I gotta find out
hang on
I, I-I tried a lot of different things,
I couldn't find anything else
There was no other way to go in the house,
there was no other way to go, pretty much anywhere that I've went.
So, there's gotta be something else before-
maybe if I leave the church as soon as I get in there,
and I'll wrap up my thoughts in a second about what this is, but,
I gotta get through this first.
So I couldn't do anything in the church,
Maybe if I, just go to the right
oh.
Ohh
Ok. Woop shit
Um
Okay,
I don't- hang on, I gotta double check to make sure there- lemme check like a walkthrough or something
I'll be right back
Ok, so I looked it up, and
there's a total of three different endings.
There is
One, which is shooting yourself
And then, oddly enough, that's the only one where you get to see,
who I can only assume is, your wife again?
and then you can take the shotgun and you can go outside
uh, I'm assuming, to fight
uh, or you can just go outside, and I'm assuming, surrender yourself to the police.
Um, this is a bizarre
short, and oddly emotional game,
like, it-it's very, it-it's very astonishing
how much it can affect you in such a short amount of time.
Like, just with, in the beginning, when you pass by that tree and suddenly it turns into a woman.
That changes everything about it, because you could be a hitman,
that's trying to bury his last body, but as soon as it turns into that woman, it's like
Woah, that took a 180 really quickly.
And then, who's the guy that came over there
And then got on the ground, and I obviously murdered him,
then I was having weird flashbacks, and then
you go into the shack, and it's a church, and you
You're marrying, and you go back to the day that you married,
And then that sudden, like that immediate cut shift
to just blackness,
with the shotgun in a shack
by yourself.
That is...
that is like, heavy shit
But it's amazing,
it always amazes me
how much people can pack into such a small package, so
I, I might be wrong about a lot of this, but I think it's a guy,
whose wife, was either murdered or died
and this guy was tryna seek revenge, and all those body bags were the bodies he buried
in revenge
for the death of his wife.
And I'm not 100 percent sure on that because
the guy that comes in and then falls to the ground
I don't know who he is in relation to everybody else, but
Maybe you guys have a better idea of it,
I'd like to know what you think in the comments below.
Thank you, everybody, so much for watching, and if you got other cool games like this,
I-I really am interested in games like this because
it just goes to show,
what can be presented, in a game.
So, thank you, everybody, so much for watching
And as always, I will see you
In the next video
Buh-bye!<3 (Mark will rule the world!)